lance mccullers jr taking the hill for
the astros this evening should be a
seventh start on the season he has three
quality starts under his belt he's been
good of late the record in two and one
era at 3.58
last time he faced the angels he took
the no decision on april 5th going six
strong one of those quality starts david
fletcher starts things off for the
angels swing and a miss fletcher
toughest guy to strike out in baseball
goes down swinging on a high pitch from
lance mccullers to start this game so
one gun for shohei starts play tonight
with 21 extra base hits to lead the
american league ground ball right side
by otani coming on altuve he has it and
throws out ohtani for out number two now
lance will face mike trout where the
bases empty swing and a miss got him on
an off speed pitch good morning good
afternoon and good night to mike trout
and mccullar strikes out two in a one
two three inning it is shohei otani on
the mound for the halos tonight
making his fifth start of the year
thursday or rather tuesday against tampa
bay at the stadium it was five shutout
innings as ohtani survived another shaky
first
to end up with five scoreless innings on
the mound did not factor in the decision
through 84 pitches and one of the things
that everybody's going to be watching
tonight including us gooby is to get
shohei right a little earlier in the
start first innings have given him
trouble here's the lead miss diaz now
with the man on got him to chase it or
that is textbook that's a crossfire 98
mile an hour fastball here's michael
brantley now but shohei gets him anyway
what a pitch and you mentioned how
difficult it is matt to strike out
brantley he didn't look real comfortable
at all that at bat
a pair of first inning strikeouts for
shohei oichani
here's carlos correa now and swings at
that one and lifts it in the air in the
right center field that ball's hit
pretty well chasing his trout also
chasing out there is the right fielder
taylor ward they collide but ward holds
on to the baseball on the warning track
that's never fun to run into mike trout
for anybody taylor ward pretty
impressive at
to hold
hold on to that baseball after getting
hit by a middle linebacker
here's martine maldonado batting got him
brought it upstairs and struck out
maldonado his third strike out of the
night so top of the order now jose
altuve first time through for ohtani a
single and a walk three strikeouts look
at that pitch
that's video game stuff yeah that's dave
steve like slider where you see the
right-handed batter bailing out of the
way he was looking at he's like i'm
gonna get hit he brings it back and
catches the corner wow here's the
two-strike pitch and he swings at that
one and lifts it right to upton he
hardly had a move it was hit right at
him out there in left field but colors
in front of a guy who was a perfect four
for four yesterday
and dating back even further seven for
his last 11 with a homer and seven
driven in strike three called
late call by wagner on the two-seamer
but it's a strikeout
mcculler's fifth of the ball game will
go to the bottom of the fourth lead off
single that's only the
second hit shohei is allowed in this
ball game and here's alvarez now that is
chased and missed a splitter got him
swinging struck him out shohei's 100th
career strikeout four players since 1900
with 50 homers and a hundred k's on the
mound one out one on now for julie
guriel who had a couple of hits
yesterday got him back to back
strikeouts so now much less threatening
situation against carlos correa and
there's a pitch taken on that two-strike
delivery and outlooking is correa and
ohtani after giving up the lead-off hit
strikes out the next three ohtani four
innings two hits a walk six strikeouts
two balls in a strike to count to kyle
tucker and tucker drives it deep to left
center it sends back upton looking up
see you later into the landry's crawford
boxes for kyle tucker and the astros
lead in one to nothing tucker's seventh
of the year
kyle tucker boy he sat on the fastball
middle away and went with it only the
second home run
that ohtani has allowed this year
and both of them have been
to left-handed hitters gosselin walked
in the third the only walk mccullers has
allowed so far tonight swing and a miss
got him on a change up and gosling is
strikeout victim number seven of
mccullers a one out of no one on for the
catcher kurt suzuki swinging a miss keep
rolling land that is eight strikeouts
three in a row got him with the heater
up sway get a mess oh that was a nasty
change up just darted straight down and
mccullar strikes out the side in the six
wow what a game this has been both
pitchers threw six innings with nine
strikeouts ohtani on third base two down
here's upton breaking ball hit pretty
hard to the right side altuve loves it
he's got it throws him out wow good
pitching there we'll go to the stretch
astros leading shohei otani going to the
bottom of the seventh inning still
trailing one nothing in what has been a
really masterfully pitched game on both
sides of the scorecard corner infielders
in with straw at the play two outs that
one is chased and missed and he got him
on the split finger fastball
another strikeout for shohei that's
number 10 tonight mccullers has given up
just two hits both singles he's walked
to and struck out nine now taylor ward
who has one of just two hits allowed by
mccullers will be the next batter
and ward sends the ball the other way
well hit tucker back and
it's gone
that is off the bat a taylor ward he
connects a home run and just like that
this game is tied at one ward's second
home run of the season he's had two of
the three angel hits and that is huge we
are all tied up oh this is getting even
better so shohei is going to stay in the
game and he'll play right field for
taylor ward well it's going to be a
tight squeeze here for alex claudio one
of the best hitters in the game due up
with the go-ahead run in scoring
position there's a line drive base hit
the center field
altuve being waved home here comes a
throw from trout altuve safe astros take
a 2-1 lead
michael bradley an rbi base hit and
there are two outs with runners at the
corners now it's guriel and that's
hammered down the left field line and
that ball is gone
into the landry's crawford boxes a
three-run home run for julie guriel and
the astros lead it five to one
six of the year team leader in rbis
tacks on moore julie did a great job of
staying back against alex claudio is so
hard because it just seems to be hanging
out there
never getting to hold plate propellers
looking for his first win against the
angels since 2017
and presley delivers
ball into center field pretty well
hitched draw on the move still going
back he'll make the play in front of the
wall
and the ball game ends with a deep fly
ball of the bat of mike trout
run down by mile straw one two three
ninth inning for ryan presley
astros win it five to one